I've had this running joke I want to say
Nick's included but it's really just for
me I try to figure out where he lives
I've been talking to him here and there
trying to get hints oh man
oh man I was with smack and I was like
hey can you take a photo of me in front
of all the houses in this area and I'm
just gonna send them to him I'm gonna
gauge his reaction and see if I've got
his house what makes you feel like
that's the street his attitude tells me
he's not willing to walk very far to
some things
I was doing a photo shoot around
Pasadena
while we're in the middle of doing this
we see Nick I've been patrolling
Pasadena trying to find Nick of the year
I have a pretty good feeling that he's
nearby
[Laughter]
you inspired me man